♪ ♪
>> IT IS BEING BUILT RIGHT NOW,
BIG SECTIONS OF WALL, AND WE
WILL CONTINUE THAT.
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER, IT IS
GOING TO GET BUILT.
>> Tucker: PRESIDENT TRUMP, A
WALL ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER ONCE
AGAIN BECOMING THE CENTRAL
DEBATE IN THE CONGRESS.
ARE REPUBLICANS READY TO RALLY
BEHIND THE PRESIDENT IN THEIR
LAST WEEKS BEFORE YIELDING POWER
TO THE DEMOCRATS?
IRISHMAN JIM JORDAN IS A
REPUBLICAN, REPRESENTS THE STATE
OF OHIO, JOINED US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
HE WOULD BE WILLING TO SHUT DOWN
THE GOVERNMENT.
DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL UNITED
BEHIND HIM IN THIS?
>> REPUBLICANS THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS DOING EXACTLY WHAT
HE SAID, THAT IS WHAT WE SHOULD
BE FOCUSED ON.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAID TO
SENATOR SCHUMER, I WILL GLADLY
TAKE THAT MANTLE, I THINK HE WAS
SAYING HE WOULD GLADLY AND
PROUDLY TAKE THE MANTLE OF
DOING WHAT THE VOTERS WE
INTENDED TO DO, WHICH IS BUILD A
BORDER SECURITY WALL.
THE FREEDOM CAUCUS IN
PARTICULAR, WE TOOK A POSITION
LAST NIGHT, TUCKER, WE SUPPORT
THE PRESIDENT, $5 BILLION FOR
THE BORDER, AND LET'S REFORM
ASYLUM LAWS WHILE WE ARE AT IT,
THAT WILL ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: FOR FRUSTRATED
VIEWERS WATCHING AT HOME
WONDERING WHY THE CENTRAL
PREMISE OF THE CAMPAIGN IS STILL
REMAINS UNFULFILLED, WAS THAT
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
PAUL RYAN, WHO PREVENTED THIS
FROM HAPPENING FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS?
>> OUR LEADERSHIP NOT PUSHING
HARD ENOUGH AND PAUL NOT PUSHING
HARD ENOUGH, AND ALSO DEMOCRATS
ARE FOR OPEN BORDERS, THEY WANT
TO ABOLISH I.C.E.
SECRETARY CLINTON, SHE RAN ON A
BORDERLESS HEMISPHERE, IT IS ALL
PART OF THAT.
THE PRESIDENT TODAY MADE IT
PRETTY DARN CLEAR HE IS GOING TO
STAND FIRM AND FOCUS ON DOING
WHAT WE WERE ELECTED TO DO.
I ALWAYS SAY, WE MAKE THE SHOT
TOO COMPLICATED FOR THAT IS A
BASIC THING TO FOCUS ON HERE
DON'T GET TOO COMPLICATED, JUST
DO WHAT YOU WERE ELECTED TO DO.
WE WERE ELECTED TO BOILED A
BORDER SECURITY WALL.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE CEO OF THE GOOGLE CAME TO
CAPITOL HILL TODAY PAIR YOU
ASKED I THOUGHT THE MOST
INTERESTING QUESTION OF THE
ENTIRE HEARING.
ABOUT A LEAKED GOOGLE DOCUMENT
THAT SHOWS A GOOGLE EMPLOYEE
BRAGGING ABOUT TURNING THE
LATINO VOTE OUT IN 2016 TO HELP
HILLARY CLINTON WIN.
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF HIS
ANSWER?
>> I DON'T THINK HE GAVE AN
ANSWER.
IN THAT EMAIL FROM THE HEAD OF
THEIR MULTICULTURAL MARKETING
DIVISION, MR. PICHAI GAVE US A
SHOUT OUT, COMPLEMENT IT,
PRAISED HER WORK, THEN SAID I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT WHAT
SHE DID.
THERE WERE TWO SENTENCES KEY,
SHE SAID "WE WERE TRYING TO GET
THE LATINO VOTE," AND THE
KEYWORD IN BOTH SENTENCES WERE
"IN KEY STATES" PAIR THAT MAKES
IT POLITICAL PEER THEY WERE
FOCUSED ON THE LATINO
VOTE IN KEY STATES.
HE WENT ANSWER THE QUESTION, SO
I SAID, WHO IS RIGHT, WHO IS
WRONG, HE NEVER GOT AROUND TO
ANSWERING THAT PAIR THAT
UNDERSCORES THIS TOOK PLACE
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE EVIDENCE
OF THE MOST POWERFUL COMPANY IN
THE WORLD WORKING ACTIVELY TO
SUBVERT OUR DEMOCRACY, TO BORROW
A PHRASE YOU HERE IN
CAPITOL HILL.
WERE DEMOCRATS ABOUT THAT?
>> THAT'S MY CONCERN,
3.5 BILLION SEARCHES PER DAY
DOWN ON THESE PLATFORMS, MOST
DONE ON GOOGLE.
AND IF THEY ARE HAVING THIS KIND
OF BIAS, AND THEIR KEY PEOPLE
ARE FOCUSING ON HELPING ONE
PARTY AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
OTHER, THAT IS A PROBLEM HERE
NEVER FORGOT, WE HAVE SEEN THIS
NOT JUST WITH GOOGLE.
I KNOW PERSONALLY COME OF THE
THERE WERE FOUR REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS, FOUR CONSERVATIVES,
SHADOW BANNED BY TWEEN       TWI
SHADOW BANNED BY TWEEN       TWT
SHADOW BANNED BY TWEEN       TWR
SHADOW BANNED BY TWEEN       TW.
ONLY FOUR, THEY GOT SHADOW
BANNED.
TWITTER'S RESPONSE IS IT WAS A
GLITCH IN OUR ALGORITHM.
REALLY?
WHAT DID YOU PUT IN THE
ALGORITHM?
THEIR NAMES?
THIS IS THE KIND OF RESPONSE WE
GET FROM THESE FOLKS, WITH THE
POWER THEY HAVE COME AT
3.5 BILLION SEARCHES PER DAY,
ALL THE PEOPLE ON TWITTER EVERY
DAY, THEY HAVE THIS KIND OF
POWER AND THEY WON'T ADMIT
BIAS IN FRONT OF US WHEN WE SEE
IT IN AN EMAIL LEAKED FROM
GOOGLE ITSELF.
THAT IS A CONCERN, THAT IS WHY
WE HAVE THE HEARING.
I WISH WE WOULD HAVE GOTTEN A
LITTLE MORE IN THE FORM OF AN
ANSWER FROM HIM.
>> Tucker: THESE COMPANIES
OPERATE AS "PLATFORMS" UNDER AN
EXEMPTION GIVEN TO THEM BY THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS UNDER THE
COMMUNICATIONS ACT, YOU ARE
AWARE OF THIS.
WHY NOT TAKE THAT AWAY TOMORROW?
>> WE SHOULD.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF BILLS WE
SHOULD LOOK AT AND THINK ABOUT
ACTUALLY TAKING THAT AWAY.
CONGRESSMAN HAVE BILLS, THEY
WOULD SAY YOU ARE NO LONGER A
NEUTRAL PLATFORM PAID WHEN THEY
ARE MAKING AND LIMITING
POINTS OF VIEW, YOU ARE NOW A
PUBLISHER, YOU ARE, IN EFFECT, A
NEWSPAPER.
THAT IS THE CASE, THERE IS A
DIFFERENT LAW TO GOVERN YOU, AND
YOU ARE NO LONGER IMMUNE FROM
LIABILITY.
WE MAY HAVE TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION.
WE MAY HAVE TO LOOK AT BREAKING
THESE COMPANIES.
I DON'T KNOW.
THERE'S A PROBLEM, THERE APPEARS
TO BE A BIG PROBLEM, AND WE NEED